اجرى دبلوماسيون روس وامريكيون مباحثات في
مدينه اسطنبول التركيه وقال نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سرجاريه بكوف ان
المباحثات يتناولت مصادر القلق بنسبه
للطرفين معربا عن امله في ان تعود
العلاقات بين موسكو واشنطن الى طبيعتها مع
الوقت واضاف ريب كوفا ان بلاده لن تبادر
الى اقتراح اجراء مفاوضات مع واشنطن من
اجل ابرام اتفاق الجديده في مجال
الاستقلال الاستراتيجي واوضح ان روسيا لن
تقترح ايضا على الولايات المتحده اجراء
مفاوضات بشان ضمانات الامنيه التي تخلت
عنها واشنطن بحجه الاحداث في اوكرانيا
جاتني قال رئيس نادي ليفربول ان بلاده
مستعده لمواصله اتصالاتها مع واشنطن على
مستوى اجهزه الاستخبارات للعمل على قضايا
تبادل الاسرى مؤكدا ان الاتصالات مع
واشنطن على مستوى اجهزه الاستخبارات
اقتراحها جانب الامريكي وستمر واستبعد
بوتن في ختام زيارته الى قرغيزيا ان تكون
هذه الاتصالات ممهده مفاوضات المعلومات
المتحده بخصوص قضايا اخرى تهم البلددين
رباط الحب
في موضوع تبادل الاسرى يجري عبر الجهاز
الامن الفدرالي والاتصالات مستمره ويمكن
القول انها لم تتوقف يوما على مستوى اجهزه
الاستخبارات ويمكن ان تكون هناك عمليات
تبادل اخرى ولا نرفض مواصله هذا العمل
بشان ما اذا كان يمكن اعتبار هذه
الاتصالات مقدمه للحوار مع واشنطن بخصوص
قضايا اخرى فهذه مساله نوعيه جدا ولم نضع
امامنا هدفا للانطلاق منها الى مفاوضات
اخرى الا انها تخلق جو عاما لكن في سياق
هذه المفاوضات لا تجري مناقشه اي مسائل
اخرى
واكد رئيس الروسيا ان جميع الاطراف
المشاركه في عمليه التسويه في اوكرانيا
ستعين عليها في نهايه المطاف القبول
بالحقائق على الارض وفق تعبير
رسائل صوت
انجليزيه العسكريه في اوكرانيا قد يطول
كنت اعني امد التسويه العمليه العسكريه
تسير بشكل طبيعي ولا مشاكل تواجهها اما
مسار تسويه بشكل عام فنعم ربما لن يكون
سهلا وسيحتاج وقتا معيانا جميع المشاركين
في هذه العمليه سيتعين عليهم في نهايه
المطاف القبول بالوقائع على الارض